from the corona virus pandemic many
businesses are closed or only offering
food to go and layoffs are widespread
vladimir duthiers is tracking the plight
of the restaurant business Vlad is that
the workers or owners who are suffering
the most here Anthony
it is both with cities and states
ordering restaurants and bars closed
except for takeout everyone is feeling
the pinch take-out requires fewer
employees but it also requires
restaurants to alter their menus in
order to survive if they can this is hot
side here burgers fried chicken
sandwiches fries shishitos all that
stuff for nearly a year nick fanner
still has been serving drinks and food
inside his neighborhood cocktail bar
nobody told me but that all changed last
week when new york restaurants and bars
were ordered to go takeout only so what
do you think you will be able to do to
keep the lights on I mean for us we have
some money set aside we're gonna try to
keep it there as long as possible but
hopefully just being able to run with
delivery and take-out options for a bit
it's gonna be able to help the plan to
pare down the menu and follow New York
rules to become exclusively a takeout
restaurant you've been in the business
for a long time you you've seen ups and
downs but you've probably never seen
anything else nothing like this at all
you know everybody's gonna kind of
weather it together the day after this
interview Knicks partner called to say
the math wasn't going to work out they
decided to shut down completely
it's a scene playing out around the
country as restaurants and bars struggle
to stay open through take out only
mandates in New York Emmeline Zhou is
offering a reduced price takeout menu at
little tongue noodle shops thanks to a
grant from the nonprofit rethink food
that will help her continue to pay staff
how are you feeling about the future you
worried who's not worried I think that
the best thing that we can do right now
is members of this community with a
means to provide is to be that beacon of
hope and inspiration that things will
get better and restaurant workers are
getting hit very hard it's now
officially been a week since shift
Bethenny Gordon lost her waiting job
from a French restaurant in Philadelphia
with no salary and tips she worries
about how to pay for the essentials give
me a sense of your economic picture yeah
we we all my roommates and I have
student loans okay and like I said we
don't know about rent and utilities
obviously groceries will be ok for now
Ashleigh Greg lost her seven-year-old
son to cancer in 2018 and still faces
the cost of his treatment she was let go
from her bartending job in Ohio when the
bar had to shut its doors we have
medical bills and everything that we
need to catch up on them so I started
working at the brewery April of 2019 but
despite her concerns
she says she's equally worried about her
former bosses I'm more concerned about
the owners I'm concerned about them
because you know this was very
livelihood if you're looking for ways
you can help there are virtual tip jars
online that let you send money directly
to restaurant servers who are out of
work and of course order that takeout
whenever possible I got dozens of menus
I can share with them with all of you on
Twitter because 15 million people work
in the restaurant industry so it is a
big big piece of the economy yeah it
sure is raw rooting for it I mean one of
the tricky things though is the margin
on food is not great you know you need
those drinks to pay the rent typically
yeah and and it's just it's the really
difficult part is they don't know how
long they're gonna have to be
closed for and there's a limited amount
of cash hopefully some landlords will be
able to forgive them some rent or at
least stretch it out so that these
places can stay with it he's right
though when she said who's not worried
yeah trick is if you you have to figure
out a way not to be consumed by it
because if you think about it the way
that I do it'll just take you in a very
dark place so we just have to figure out
ways to keep going